thanks to Paradox for sponsoring a
portion of today's
video okay I got all the samples we need
we're really going to blow this Theory
wide open map Pat to Enterprise one to
beam
[Applause]
up wait wait wait wait something's not
right we're losing him this shouldn't be
happening k me why do we keep using
these
things hello Internet welcome to film
Theory the show that boldly goes where
no show has gone before well except that
other time we went where no show has
gone before yeah it's been a minute
since we've talked about Star Trek on
this channel 3 and 1/2 million minutes
to be exact over 7 years and man has the
series really seen a Revival since that
time sadly there haven't been any more
movies but did you know that between
streaming and YouTube there are more
Star Trek shows released after our
previous Theory than before it wrap your
head around that one it is mindblowing
and there are even more on the way just
saying all you trekkies out out there
are eating good right now but beyond the
strange new worlds they're exploring the
one thing I'm most excited about is the
potential for new memes feels like it's
been too long since we got a new Picard
face palm or sarcastically surprised
Kirk or really it's impressive how many
lines from the Star Trek series have
just entered into everyday speech you
got He's dead Jim and set your phasers
to stun and of course the oldtime
classic beat me up Scotty for all you
Zoomers watching who only recognize that
as something your grandparents say this
was the catchphrase that everyone in the
original Star Tre show would say when
they were ready to teleport back to
their starship the Enterprise see the
original Star Trek was made on the cheap
and I mean the cheap cheap that's why
all the costumes looked like bedazzled
sweaters and the alien planets looked
like they were made from papier-mâché
it's probably because they were
bedazzled sweaters and paper mâché
because they didn't want to blow the
budget on every episode flying down to
whatever New World they were visiting
they invented a form of teleportation
known as The Transporter that basically
cost the production team nothing you
just step into a tube get surrounded by
glitter swirling and water filmed upside
down in slow motion and then you get
beamed wherever you need to go as long
as it's in range honestly it's a cool
piece of sci-fi Tech that's helped to
craft the utopian future that Star Trek
is so well known for or did it see the
transporter has been the topic of
discussion amongst the fan base for a
long time with a bunch of philosophical
debates around whether or not the person
who steps out of the transporter is the
same person that went in see the way the
technology works in the cannon of the
show is that it breaks the people it
transports down to the atomic level it
then beams them to where they need to go
and then it reassembles them there so is
that really the same person or just some
weird copy with all the same thoughts
and memories it's a classic ship of
thesis debate which I can now site
without having to explain too much
because you all know it from the finale
of ju division cgp gray actually has an
excellent video covering that exact
discussion today though we wanted to
throw our hats into the ring and do
something a little bit different with it
switching our phasers from
philosophizing to analyzing cuz I think
there's a truly dark secret lying here
inside this piece of technology one so
dark and so devastating that the
citizens of the Federation should be
running as far and fast as they they can
to avoid this thing after diving back
into the Trek series I'm convinced that
the Transporters are weapons of mass
destruction that could also be
potentially poisoning your brain yep
after this one you're never going to
dream of stepping aboard the Enterprise
again put on your red shirts friends
we're beaming aboard so first of all
what are the Transporters exactly well
they do exactly what they sound like
they break you down adom by atom and
then transport you from one location to
another in a form of teleportation
reassembling you on the other end but
how does that actually work well there
are a few steps first whatever is being
transported to scann by the machine down
to the molecular level then as the
original series put it the molecules in
your body are converted into energy then
beamed into this chamber and reconverted
back into their original pattern okay
that's a bit of a techno Babble solution
but for the Sci-Fi setting sure checks
out and that certainly looks like What's
Happening Here with all the characters
dissolving into light and then
reappearing from the same sort of light
but just on a surface level there are
some pretty horrifying things that can
come from this sort of Technology
malfunctioning the Star Trek shows
actually get a lot of mileage from these
sorts of accidents in their story lines
beam the captain and Spark back up we
don't have the power They'll Come Aboard
a mass a D in flesh and I realized
there's no margin for error want to add
them out of place and po you never come
back believe me we'll be talking a lot
more about them today but let's actually
think about what they're doing here
they're converting the matter of objects
people clothes hair what they eat for
breakfast all of that stuff and turning
that into energy that should be setting
off some alarm bells in your brain here
and this is our first big reason why no
one should using the Transporters
they're very easy to weaponize see
whenever you start talking about
converting Mass into energy and vice
versa there's a very real and very
famous scientific equation that lets us
do exactly this in fact it's one of the
discoveries that Albert Einstein is most
famous for E equals mc^ squ all that
equation is talking about is energy
equals mass time the speed of light
squared it's a pretty simple equation
right sure but the result is some crazy
huge numbers when you consider that the
speed of light is almost 300 million m a
second so squaring that that means
you're getting a lot of energy from a
very teeny tiny amount of mass this is
the idea that nuclear energy was based
off of seriously did you know that a
chunk of uranium the size of a golf ball
in a nuclear reactor can produce more
energy than
3,200 tons of coal this is why and
that's with modern-day technology that's
awful at converting mass and energy we
only get a fraction of what's available
to us and we're left with a ton of
unusable waste afterward but if you can
convert matter into energy perfectly
like these Transporters would need to do
it they're moving people around intact
well to convert just a single gram of
matter to Pure Energy with 100%
efficiency that would be equivalent to
89.9 ter of energy or the energy
released by the detonation of over
21,000 tons of TNT if you scaled it up
to an average sized human man right
around 200 lb or 90 kg Einstein's
equation means that you're getting an
energy equivalent of this crazy number
that means nothing to you fair basically
that would be the same as 54,000
explosions ions just like the little boy
bomb dropped on Hiroshima back in World
War II in short the Star Trek
Transporters have the potential to be
some of the most devastating super
weapons in the universe an explosive
more potent than anything we've ever
seen on Earth which you could just set
off from anywhere you'd like within the
range of the transporter oh I'm sorry
you getting bullied by a Romulan warbird
just transport a Tic Tac on board and
let it blow up instead of
rematerializing and before you jump down
to the comments to tell me I'm wrong and
this would never happen yeah I do
realize that there are certain
safeguards in place in the show
throughout all the episodes of Star Trek
I've watched there's never once been an
accident caused by the matter energy
conversion but there have been many
people who've modified and weaponized
their Transporters before throughout the
franchise we see Transporters disable
weapons weapons get modified with
Transporter Tech to shoot through walls
even replacing people mid transport to
invade a ship given all of that is this
sort of matter to energy bomb really
that much of a stretch or is it more of
a storyline that's yet to be written now
before we explore the other horrible
ways using a transporter could go wrong
let's take a moment to to thank our
sponsor for today's video Paradox
interactive and their newest game Star
Trek infinite Star Trek infinite is a 4X
strategy game basically the point is to
explore expand exploit and exterminate
all very much in line with the many
factions of the Star Trek Galaxy you can
choose to play as the Federation the
Klingon Empire the Romulan star Empire
and the Kardashian Union of course cuz
I'm a good at two shoes I jumped at the
chance to play my first game as the
Federation and so I quickly started
exploring every system that I could but
things got tense in a hurry the romulans
attacked a Kling on Colony leaving
thousands dead and it was up to me to
broker a piece did I do it well to be
honest I haven't gotten to the end of
that campaign yet there's so much to do
in Star Trek infinite it's one of those
games where you get into it you blink
and suddenly 16 hours have passed what
blew my mind though was learning that
each of the different civilizations have
a completely different Mission tree each
one focusing on the things that lore
nerds like me love about the show sure I
played as the Federation so I did a
bunch of diplomacy negotiations and
exploration but if you play as the
Klingons they focus on warfare the
Kardashian are great at spying the
romulans are masters of stealth all of
those story focuses line up perfectly
with what we see from the civilizations
in the Tre shows that plus the fact that
so many of the story events pulled from
things that actually happened in the
Star Trek universe tell me that there
was just a ton of love and effort and
Care put into the crafting of this game
if you're a giant treky and enjoy 4X
strategy games then you have to check
out Star Trek infinite thanks to Paradox
for sponsoring that portion of the video
and now it's time we beam back down into
our discussion as to why the
Transporters should terrify you so we
are already know that putting a human
into a transporter would create enough
explosive energy that you could wipe a
planet clean but the horrifying
scientific implications of these
futuristic inventions don't just stop
there see when you break things down to
the atomic level you can do way more
than just move those atoms around and
piece them back together you can also
rearrange those atoms to create
something brand new and we see this
concept used all the time in the form of
Star Trek replicators a replicator is a
machine that can create and recycle
things replicators were originally used
to synthesize meals on demand but in
later series they were used to create
larger non-f food items as Commander
rker explains you've seen something as
fresh and tasty as meat but
inorganically materialized out of
patterns used by our Transporters
materialized by our Transporters so the
replicators are using the same matter to
energy conversion technology it's taking
an existing reservoir of matter and
energy and using those components as
building blocks to copy a pattern stored
in the computer of Whatever item you
want say for instance a nice juicy steak
it's kind of a lot like a 3D printer but
then where are they getting all that
matter from obviously they don't have
some other Stak in some other room
teleporting onto your plate and they're
not creating matter from nothing because
that's scientifically impossible it has
to come from somewhere so where's that
steak from poop crapola we actually
learned this in Star Trek Discovery it's
made of our that's the base material
that we use in our replicators we
deconstruct it to the atomic level and
then reformed the atam it's pretty good
for yep everyone in Star Trek is
literally just eating poop rearranged at
the subatomic level I don't know if
Intergalactic piece is worth the price
now I'm not just bringing this up
because it's funny things get really
creepy when you take this to The Logical
extreme if the replicators are using the
same matter energy conversion technology
as the Transporters and the replicators
are basically able to create things from
scratch using a basic set of atomic
building blocks could you just print out
clones of humans yeah 100% you could and
that isn't even something that we need
to speculate about I'm Commander William
reker from the Federation Starship
Enterprise that's not possible I'm will
reker yeah this happens multiple times
throughout the course of the franchise
with varying results Brad Boyer's cloned
in a transporter accident in Star Trek
lower decks Captain Kirk was also split
into during the episode The Enemy Within
which not only cloned his body but
divided his personality between them the
most famous example of this though is a
transporter accident from the Next
Generation and the episode Second
Chances where you see William reker
materialized both on the Enterprise and
back on the planet that he was being
transported from this second will rker
was more or less his own person taking
on the name Thomas rker complete with a
personality distinct from Will based on
their different experiences after being
split this of course prompts a lot of
philosophical questions raised by the
fan base even the show isn't sure which
one of these is quote unquote real which
of them is real well that's the thing
both you were both materialized from a
complete pattern but even if we don't
want to get philosophical about this
think of the Practical ramifications
here what's to stop someone from
modifying a transporter and making a
clone of someone anyone they wanted at
any time they wanted that person would
have no paper trail no one would know
they exist and that has some dark
complications they'd be a perfect
assassin a perfect Alibi a perfect
victim that right there that is
horrifying most importantly of all the
transporter clone would absolutely be
made of poop and not only can
Transporters make copies they can also
create new life in the Voyager episode 2
vix two of the ship's crew tuac and neix
are accidentally combined into a single
life form after a transport gone wrong
this new creature is is named Tu vix get
it it's their names combined yeah I see
what you're doing there Star Trek can't
get sneaky stuff like that past me
anyway during the transport the pair's
DNA strands merge to create something
entirely new again this opens the door
to horrific moral quandaries tux is his
own person with his own thoughts and
feelings and so obviously he's not going
to be all that Keen on dying so when the
opportunity arises to bring the two crew
members Back to Life by pumping two Vic
back through the transporter voyager's
Captain is faced with a terrible choice
to this day whether or not this was the
right thing to do or if it was outright
murder has challenged the fan base all
because of these dangerous Transporters
and how they have uncertain effects on
the people they're teleporting no one
tell the trekkies that Tu vix could have
lived they just could have brought back
the other two as poop clones now
creating clones INF fusions of people
who go through the transport process is
a terrifying concept but the worst one
for me reason number three you should
never use a transporter it has the
potential to slowly drive you insane
until you're erased from reality
transporter psychosis is in fact a real
thing in the the Star Trek universe
transporter psychosis was diagnosed in
the year 20209 it is caused by a
breakdown of neurochemical molecules
during transport this disease affected
motor skills and reasoning ability and
caused paranoid delusions dementia and
hallucinations in Universe they
eventually found the cause of
Transporter psychosis and fixed it but
for a while especially during the era of
Captain Kirk every time a character was
transported there was a chance that they
would literally lose their mind but you
see the fact that this is just a thing
that can and has happened in the Star
Trek franchise got me one wondering what
else could these Transporters do to your
head what's the worst thing that these
could be used for clearly what's normal
for a transporter is that you go in
conscious and you come out conscious
remembering all the same stuff that's
fairly consistent for the series but if
you really dig into the lore of this
thing you're also conscious while you're
being transported in the Next Generation
episode realm of fear the crew of the
Enterprise beam over to a derelict ship
but they run into some trouble I'll have
to send you over one at a time Commander
because of bandwidth limitations and the
transport cycle will take a bit longer
how I F four or 5 Seconds about twice
the normal time the extended transport
cycle is played up for drama in the
episode because one of the crew
Lieutenant Barkley has a transporter
phobia smart man considering everything
we've been talking about today but the
reason that I bring this episode up is
that we actually see the transport cycle
through Barkley's eyes and he
experiences the whole thing multiple
times and this isn't unique to just
Barkley have have you ever seen anything
during transport sometimes my visor
picks up resonance patterns from matter
energy conversion this proves that your
conscious during transport you're aware
of your body being split apart and
reassembled now that in and of itself is
weird and it creates a complimentary
portion of existential dread with your
instant teleportation but on the whole
thankfully it's over in just 2 to 4
seconds so at least it's short but what
if it didn't take just a couple of
seconds what if you got trapped mid
transport for whatever reason well it's
something that's happened before in
another Next Generation episode relix
Scotty from the original series saves
himself from dying a slow death by
locking himself mid transport Within the
pattern buffer in basic terms he was
transported but then intentionally never
rematerialized on the other end so he
just existed in this ethereal state of
unbeing for decades additionally
something that they don't touch on in
this episode is the fact that given the
rules and logic we just figured out
Scotty should have experienced all of
that time mid transport in the actual
show it doesn't seem like he realizes
exactly how much time has passed but if
characters like Barkley experienced what
it was like mid- transport Scotty should
have as well can you imagine decades
completely isolated unable to move or
well do anything but still fully aware
of every minute of it that would wreak
havoc on your brain you know it's funny
in the actual episode Scotty did this to
himself to save his own life but I can't
think of a more perfect way to trap
imprison and torture someone to force
them to be alive and aware in the state
of unbeing all intentionally that right
there that is horrible and you know
what's even worse the cherry on top this
replicated poop Sunday listen to this
completely intact just's less than
.3% signal degradation your pattern can
degrade meaning that you can literally
lose parts of yourself within the
transporter that right there that is a
real thing that's possible in the Star
Trek universe in fact it happened in
this very episode Another unseen
character was also put into this limbo
State alongside Scotty but his patterns
degraded
53% he's gone hear that his pattern
degraded more or less killing him so not
only is the transporter potentially the
perfect prison the ultimate form of
complete isolation and torture it could
also be a way to just slowly pick you
apart over the course of decades any way
you look at it the transporter is a
terrifying piece of technology not only
does it have the potential to create
explosions more powerful than anything
we can produce today not only can It
create clones of the people it teleports
or combine them together not only does
it potentially reconstitute the people
who use it out of feal matter but it can
literally alter your brain and leave you
in a limbo as you slowly lose both your
mind and your body to the pattern you
know what after hearing all that please
please for the love of Kirk do not beam
me up Scotty but hey that's just a
theory a film Theory and
[Music]
cuts